So I have an emergency farm stand delivery
I need to get done this evening.
Normally, I would bring my cooler with ice,
but I'm gonna try this electric cooler.
It's like a portable mini refrigerator,
and you can set the temperature exactly how you want it.
It plugs into the back of my SUV,
and I can control the temperature from the keypad right here.
It will even freeze.
So if you're needing to freeze anything or keep something frozen, um,
over long periods of time while traveling,
this is perfect. This super lightweight,
super easy for me to maneuver into the car.
It comes with this cooler bag for extra hot days in the car.
This insulates the cooler and helps regulate the temperature.
You can still control the controls.
I'm gonna be using this now instead of my old cooler.
Revised for milk drop offs.
Having the control of the temperature is really important
when delivering milk, and this makes it a perfect for the job.
I'm also gonna be using it on our upcoming camping trip,
and I'm so excited to be able to take raw milk with us camping.
Just need to rally up these kids and get this milk delivered.